[Music]
this is the international space station
the u.s runs a majority of this portion
while russia operates this smaller
section of the spacecraft but now the
whole enterprise faces questions about
its future
distances
but the director of russia's space
agency didn't specify when after 2024
the country could leave well if russia
were to quit the station the station
program would end some space experts say
russia may now be using the
international space station as leverage
against the west
which imposed a slew of sanctions on
russia following moscow's invasion of
ukraine nasa is committed to keeping the
spacecraft running through 2030 and
other partners have voiced support for
that timeline but russia's departure
could complicate that plan and strain
the future of scientific research
the first component of the international
space station was a russian part that
went into orbit in 1998. the
international space station was
constructed over a number of years and
is actually by far
the largest construction project ever
attempted in space leroy chao is a
retired u.s commander of the
international space station and he was
one of the astronauts involved in the
building of the spacecraft since the
launch of the first part also known as a
module the us russia and other partner
countries have spent about a hundred
billion dollars over the course of more
than 10 years bolting the station
together today the spacecraft is the
size of a football field that consists
of 16 modules space station is composed
of a russian segment and then the
american segment is dependent on both
the russian side and the u.s segment to
operate correctly
so what does russia currently provide
for the station let's zoom in on these
two modules which are the backbone of
the international space station and they
make sure that the spacecraft stays in
orbit and that astronauts can survive in
space they comprise
most of the thermal control system and
the life support and attitude control
system and that attitude control system
is key to making sure the space station
stays afloat the giant spacecraft is
about 250 miles away from the earth's
surface where it's known as the low
earth orbit and it needs to move at a
speed of about 17 000 miles per hour to
stay there but there's a thin atmosphere
that slows down the station so the two
russian modules have engines and
thrusters that help the spacecraft
maintain its altitude we're going to
fire
the engines on the aft end of the space
station the low earth orbit is also home
to thousands of tons of space debris and
the engines and thrusters help the
spacecraft maneuver around the clutter
so if russia ends up leaving the station
nasa and other partners would need to
come up with another solution to keep it
operational possible option is that if
we could design and launch a module that
would create recreate the functions of
the russian segment and launch it and
attach it to the station before they
decide to quit but chaos says this
solution isn't practical because
building and testing new modules could
take months if not years and cost
billions of dollars meanwhile nasa and
the white house are also working on
other contingency plans for instance in
june northrop grumman boosted the
station using its spacecraft
but if nasa and other partners can't
keep the lab in orbit that would
jeopardize a series of research projects
that can only be done in space most of
the research aboard iss is really
biomedical we're studying the astronauts
and cosmonauts that are up there and the
studies include how microgravity and
higher radiation could affect the human
body as well as how fast astronauts can
re-adapt to the earth's environment we
need to understand
and mitigate the negative effects of
being in space for so long before we can
send the crew to a distant destination
like mars so the biggest effect of
course is if russia quits the station
you know that would be the end of the
program but russia's potential
withdrawal from the international space
station also means the country will have
to give up its own research aboard the
spacecraft so moscow is laying out plans
to start deploying its own orbiting
outposts in 2028 but constructing a
space station won't be an easy task
especially as moscow faces a barrage of
sanctions imposed by the west including
ones on its space sector will cut off
more than half of russia's high-tech
imports it'll degrade their aerospace
industry including their space program
russia's trying to use the iss as
leverage probably because of the war in
ukraine and tension between our
countries
that was just something that the russian
leadership decided to to kind of poke
the us with russia's space agency didn't
provide further comment about its exit
or whether the decision was a response
to western sanctions but the agency has
said it would complete its obligations
to its partners until its departure nasa
said it hasn't received a withdrawal
notice from russia so for now a major
symbol of post-cold war collaboration
has a few more years to stay in orbit
you